hi herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video leute ich bin auch im urlaub mal
wieder wie gefühlt 50 prozent meiner
lebenszeit in einem spielwarengeschäft
gewesen ich habe etwas gefunden das mega
heftig und wir müssen testen auch
funktioniert und zwar enteignet blums
also anti schwerkraft balance die
angeblich gegen die schwerkraft in der
luft stehen bleiben bzw übertrieben
langsam auch den wohnort der
unterschiedliche durchmesser 1 x 50 cm
wenn man kurz der junge neben den 50
zentimetern weg relativ normal und
menschlich aus
wenn ihr hier guckt bei 90 zentimetern
der junge ist komplett am trippen seinen
kopf das irgendwie aufgespalten und so
wird übertrieben krank wir machen den
hartz iv es draußen findet gerade mega
stark weil die sind an der nordsee wir
setzen das erstmal innen drin also im
haus auf die dinger das funktioniert und
dann brauchen weil doch mit wem wird das
mega attraktiv legen wir los legen los
seht ihr das hier die aufschrift wie
mainz 330 weit links steht voll
aufgeblasen ist erst schwere los der
rostet hinten auf deutschen autobahnen
aufgelöst
[Musik]
es ist jetzt schon übertrieben dünn und
es geht auch 50 cm lange ich das
beschreiben soll für jetzt findet man
das ist so megawatt die oberfläche aber
irgendwie cool ein glücklicher mit
aufgeblasen komponist bewährt kannst du
dir vorstellen dass das irgendwie
schwerelos sein soll
gut jeder stein ja da gibt auf jeden
fall noch deutlich mehr luft dann habe
ich mir natürlich einiges gutmachen
der ballwechsel wächst weiter mega cool
als viele denken nicht dass diese dinge
deine decke vorgeführt aber ich glaube
darin mag dass er funktionieren aber
kaufen weil dem winziger müsst ihr
unbedingt dranbleiben so ich würde sagen
dafür jetzt langsam 50 meter oder oder
geht da noch was rein männlichen hart
ausfiel
er könnte schon etwas eingehen
[Musik]
überschreiten die machen uns jetzt alle
erst mal ab wenn ziel
ich weiß noch nicht genau wofür dass wir
da sein soll dass man so mit worten kann
wir werden das ding jetzt einfach nur
eine luft und schauen wie schwerkraft
oder sie präsent wie schwer ist es ein
anti schwerkraft wallungen sein kann
da muss mehr luft rein oder raus
also wir probieren das jetzt noch mal
defekt schneller als normaler luftballon
nein kann ich nur fünf zentimeter
[Musik]
kochplatz kleid
ich brauche unbedingt bitte eure hilfe
gleich beim rosenball müssen wir alle
zusammen aber die regeln einfach vor
allem die sache der blumen bei dem kreis
ist ja die hochreine ist doppelter
durchmesser das doch bitte aber um 38
sache luft die sein muss
[Applaus]
hierdurch dreimal viermal r-quadrat
gleich ordentlich mehr geworden
wirklich bewerten werden wir das einmal
hoch vielleicht müssen wir sogar noch
mehr luft rein machen aber hey da merkt
man erst mal drauf machte schon
aufstehen
gleich machen wir noch mehr rein mit
einem finger der pflicht ist
er kommt etwas zu dir leute alle sagen
das werde ich gut ich muss jetzt weiter
wenn ihr mann nicht dafür ein
explodierter kraft rein gemacht und
jetzt mittlerweile ist die oberfläche
richtig hart ich hätte nicht gedacht
dafür bewerben von bayern anfang des
megacity und beleg der schwerelosen raum
auf gewerbe mit echten jetzt noch mal
mein gott
dafür müssen einfach in der luft
getrieben weil der winkel von ricarda
übertrieben aber ja wir gehen jetzt
einmal hoch
wie hoch werden die hellgrüne sehen ihr
glaube ich was passiert ist sebastian
gerade es oft einfach der grüne geplatzt
und einem gestörten final alter richtig
gestört denn liegen die überreste weg
von mir befindet sich der ort noch nicht
fertig aber gebt ihm jetzt schon
riesengroß und da drin befindet sie
einfach noch diese kugel die anfängt zu
leicht wenn man ihn darauf ein welche
noch 90 zentimeter eigentlich nicht mehr
junges ding hier zum 20 mal für einen
kopf
sie müssen erstmal am besten raus gehen
und damit auch wieder raus kommen wir
durch die tür offiziell begangen
zwischen ballon und er so groß dass er
nicht mehr durch die tür passt damit
ihren brauchen können wir werden
natürlich erstmal drin testen aber dann
ist uns überlegen entlasten bitte luft
raus oder wir probieren durchzug
vassallo bei einer natürlichkeit
explodieren kann als aller erstes mal
der guten test erstmals über man kann
das ding hier einfach anders beleuchtet
das ist der garant andrej das wasser aus
jetzt hätten wir mal wie dieser ballon
mit dieser leuchten bringen über auch
kriegen kann
okay für möglichst der kriegt auch noch
besser wirst du sagen
[Musik]
die videoarbeit probieren kiesewetter
wirklichen einsetzen 1 1 zum abschluss
wirklich drauf nein mit dem bau weiter
hoch
jetzt hat man gesehen dass hat man
gesehen
damit jetzt locker das klingt dann
einfach noch an
egal wer täglich nach michael haben
leider nicht mehr gefunden die
irgendwann gewischt lange man sich drauf
gelegt habe mich dann gegründet lange
mitgemacht leute dafür auf jeden fall
ein lustiges experimentiert video mit
anti schwerkraft balance anlass gerne
leichter schaden
beschreibung verweisen zu basteln
jahresverdienst ja dann bis zum nächsten
meistens folgt